" À cause de l’épidémie
de coronavirus
les députés ont mis fin
à la pause parlementaire
prévue pendant les municipales
et rouvert l’Assemblée nationale
pour une séance extraordinaire. "
On apprend dans le pays que tout s’arrête,
mais on apprend dans le même temps
parce qu’Emmanuel Macron
est très clair, il dit que
la vie démocratique et le contrôle
du Parlement doivent continuer.
" Toute l’action du gouvernement
et du Parlement
doit être désormais tournée
vers le combat contre l’épidémie. "
Et donc pour nous ça commence,
2 mois de travail, du non-stop.
Les plateaux sont réduits
au strict minimum
il n’y a plus qu’une présentatrice
et puis il y a une équipe aux «4 cols».
" Regardez cette salle des Quatre Colonnes,
d’habitude, et bien, elle grouille de monde
avant les Questions au Gouvernement
et bien là, voilà, raison sanitaire oblige,
il y a 2 équipes seulement.
" Dès que quelqu’un tousse,
j’ai les oreilles qui se dressent évidemment.
Il me reste
encore un peu de gel,
je ne sais pas comment
je vais faire tout à l’heure. "
Il y a un côté évidemment décalé,
étonnant dans cette situation de l’Assemblée,
des députés, lorsqu’au début
ils ne sont qu’une grosse vingtaine
dans l’hémicycle qui peut
en contenir plus de 500.
" J’invite les orateurs, à ne pas poser
les mains sur le flexible du micro.
Celui-ci sera nettoyé après
chaque usage par un huissier.
Je vous indique enfin
que l’hémicycle a été désinfecté
et sera nettoyé avant
et après chaque séance. "
Entre des Questions au Gouvernement
qui vont avoir lieu toutes les semaines,
des projets de loi
qui vont se succéder,
on parle de projets
de loi d’urgence sanitaire,
avec des restrictions de liberté.
On parle de projets de loi de finances
qui engagent des sommes très importantes.
" Les grands chiffres font
évidemment froid dans le dos
comme vous l’avez dit,
Monsieur le Président.
On atteint 183,5 milliards d’euros de déficit
c’est-à-dire que nous doublons
le déficit de 91 milliards
prévus en budget initial
et 115% de dette. "
Donc le travail de LCP ne s’arrête pas
du tout, au contraire…
LCP a suivi des députés
qui ont remis la blouse.
Ils étaient médecins,
pharmaciens,
des députés qui se démenaient
pour trouver des masques.
" - Le député médecin
Philippe Chalumeau
reçoit à son cabinet médical.
Disponible 1 à 2 jours
par semaine jusque-là,
il y passe tout son temps
en ce moment.
- Je vais d'abord
vous donner un masque. "
Pour moi,
cette phase de confinement
et le fait qu’on se soit vraiment
recentrés sur notre mission première
à savoir,
le suivi parlementaire,
l’explication de ce
qui se passe au Parlement,
ça a permis à LCP de montrer son utilité
vraiment dans cette période.
Lorsqu’il se passe
quelque chose à l’Assemblée,
LCP est là,
elle le fait vivre en direct
et elle explique
aux téléspectateurs ce qui se passe,
les enjeux, et en quoi concrètement
demain ça va changer leur quotidien.